we kept being told that we were a black
show next thing i knew i woke up in
geometry class
naked through the years i've seen
the colors and shapes and cultures of
people who resonated with that show
because
we were them
and people especially who are fans of
the show what do they say to you the
most when they see you when is living
single coming back
are you and overton really married is
that your hair
oh khadija oh please oh please oh please
can i miss work tomorrow so i can spend
the day with camille too please please
let's go back to the living color well
him name is danny
i'm american i'm very funny and i think
i love he
the audition process was the most
grueling thing i've ever been through
i have a surprise for you i was released
after the first year
and i went on to a show where i felt
that my talents and
gifts and experience could really be
fostered and so
it's a good thing in the end
kevin fraser how are you doing your
story is something that people love
let's go back to the living color
and that first season what do you
remember about the very beginning
the audition process was the most
grueling thing i've ever been through
because keenan wanted people who were
stand-ups who could also do
characters who could also write so my
first audition was to do stand-up and i
had a bit where i did
like all the contestants in the miss
america pageant and then i passed that
test and then you had to go and do
improv then once you passed that then he
flew everybody from all the places we
came to la to audition at the lab
factory and
that was grueling because you had to
just show all your stuff but it was
wonderful because you got a chance to
get a sense of
all the talent that was there it was
incredible what's it like when you know
you're like i'm going to be on this
new interesting show well here's what's
interesting kevin
is that the show didn't get picked up
right away uh
they actually started making bootleg
copies of the show and it's selling them
on the street in new york i lived in
brooklyn
i knew that the show was going to be a
hit because people were copying it and
taking it
how many shows did you do we did one
pile it was an hour long pilot
and someone took it copied it and
started selling it on the street
so that's how i knew we were going to
get picked up because the buzz was
already on the street i was like this is
going to be a hit
so the energy was incredible everybody
was really hungry and
sort of checking out each other's talent
and it was uh just
explosive and new and funny
and wonderful so the season starts
yeah and all of a sudden it is this
crazy juggernaut that like
it's like must-watch tv must-watch tv
must uh shake things up tv some people
found it really controversial
some people found it you know right on
point and that's the kind of stuff that
makes people talk at the water cooler
when we used to be able to hang out at
water coolers you know what was your
favorite skit
my favorite skit was uh the heimann
family
him dead now i'm jumping in
the ones that had all them jobs because
it came out of truth you know
if you know caribbean families and in
particular jamaican families they have
i'm a doctor i'm a nurse i'm a i'm a
liar i also clean up the street i also
do that you say i'm a gardener
i'm a cook because they come here and
they're so industrious
and they want to work they want to get
educated and they all
pull their money together and do big
things
as you mentioned that skit and how it
became part of like
american vocabulary and lexicon and
people were like you're working like a
jamaican
and it came from that moment it did
because now we were
educating people about how this
particular group
is or or or wants to be it was really
powerful
came on and we laughed all the time and
i loved it because
i got a chance to really you know show
off my love for new york and my love for
the caribbean culture so it was great
your craziest story from that first year
we got sorry
thank you very much one of my favorite
moments
from that show was watching jim carrey
be able to fold his body into shapes
that don't exist
on the human realm he is fearless
he is funny he's a sweetie pie and
um you give him something and he's gonna
take it and make even more
of it and like i said he can contort
himself into all these
and all these shapes and beings and it
was really fun to watch it was really
fun to watch
someone just have no fear whatsoever no
boundaries whatsoever
and that was really freeing to go like i
ain't gonna do that but jim carrey will
so it was really good yeah how tight
were you guys what was that cast like
it was an interesting experience it was
it was tight for some because
it's a family run show so i'll just say
you know that it
there were it was tighter tight for some
and not so tight for others
keenan gave a lot of stuff to his sister
it was that hard because
that his sister was there i will say
that i get it now
i get it now it was really hard then to
see the landscape feel that i had all
this talent inside of me and all these
ideas
and that they weren't always encouraged
and they weren't always
didn't have a chance to see the light of
day and the good news though is that i
was released after the first year
and i went on to a show where i felt
that my talents and
gifts and experience could really be
fostered and so
it's a good thing in the end it was
tough in the moment right but good
is it true that you just got a call from
his assistant like don't come to work
i got a call from my agent saying don't
go to work monday morning
yeah don't go to work monday i'm like
and it was tough of course and it was
embarrassing and it was weird because it
was the hottest thing
ever and i couldn't understand what i
had done or not done
right or wrong and eventually we had a
conversation i understood the politics
of the situation
it was a there's so much there's so many
layers to it right
right i wish them well i got a great
apology
and a great explanation he actually said
to me
i had to let you go and i knew you'd be
okay so
how can you be i had to let you go
didn't explain you know i had to let you
go but i knew you'd be all right and i'm
like
okay because i am you i mean i was yeah
you were
you all are good now we're good now
actually i got you know i've had
conversations with
with who whoever i would consider the
you know offending
whatever i you know i'm good i'm good
now because i'm clear that that was an
opportunity that needed to happen
the way it did that was the show that
brought me out here so how can i have
anything but love for
for that experience and because i left
and
had a even better experience and made
even more money and the show lasted even
longer
and how can i be mad do you think they
should have a revival of
um in living color and would you go to
would you do i don't know that i'd be
invited i'll be honest with you i don't
feel
no no i wouldn't be invited oh no oh no
no no
oh no oh no oh no they've done things
and i haven't been invited i'm good
i'm good i wish them all well you know
they are there are all these articles
that come out you're not invited back
what's going on and all of a sudden you
land in this new show
yeah living singing that i didn't have
to audition for
[Music]
so talk about the contrast of like
having to go through like the uh the
the you know the juggernaut of having to
audition and audition again and
you know hope that i get in a sketch and
like beg to get on
and go to a place i had a deal at warner
brothers and like we want to do a show
about
women how they feel about each other and
their careers and how they feel about
men and oh by the way
what do you think of queen latifah i was
like i love her yes
and they were having the same kind of
meetings with her they put the two of us
together
they got yvette lee bowser to create the
show
and boom we were off and running and the
cast came together
beautifully like the first day of work
it was like oh this is gonna be a hit
i'm sorry it's just i've been really
busy working on my cosmetology thesis
purple lipstick the black woman's enemy
you told a story about this guy uh in
an older white guy saying you remind me
of the people
in my neighborhood that the show crossed
over is the point
right well you know we kept being told
that we were a black show
but i remember going to the bank one
time this little old jewish man and i
knew who he was because i'm from
brooklyn
he squeezed my arm hello beautiful i
love that show with all you beautiful
girls beautiful girls i love it it's
wonderful
and he's nothing like the demographic
that they said we had
and yet he was watching because it
reminded him of home and so
i know and through the years i've seen
the colors and shapes and cultures of
people who
resonated with that show because we were
them
that show was also important because it
showed young black professionals in a
different light
really for the first time absolutely and
uh really professional we had
you know a brother who was wearing his
hair and and you know twists and locks
and he worked
on wall street and he had a woman who
was starting her own magazine it was
really powerful and and
what's interesting is i think it still
stands today what was the secret sauce
between
the cast because it was it felt like
these people are really friends we
really were
we really are what is wrong with you
first you wipe her for vomit then you
threaten to kill her y'all are bonding
so the first moment for me was uh
latifah was so cool and you know she's
from jersey i'm from brooklyn so i felt
that energy
you know kim feels who's a legend she
was the only little black girl that was
on tv for years so like
oh you know john hinton and i both did
stand up and we knew each other from
that world
tc and erica alexander have the same
exact birthday
and once we found that oh it was on we
would take trips
together and hang out together and
celebrate births and deaths and
marriages and divorces and divorces
together it was really good
some of us have had several divorces
don't judge now that you look back on
the show
a new generation is watching it what is
it like and what are you hearing
from people now oh i hear great things
and people thanking us saying thank you
for being positive images
uh for for black people doing great
things oh
regine you know khadijah she doesn't
like to appear sentimental but
inside she sees the niceness regine you
know sinclair she don't know what the
hell she's talking about
i want to go back to the pilot episode
pilot script
of a living single what do you remember
about that
i remember feeling an energy of this is
going to work
this is going to be a hit we had already
all hung out together as a cast
and the thing that happened very quickly
is you see the script and you know the
words are on the page but there's
something that happens when we as a
cast and as a family come and bring it
to life so i knew that i could throw a
ball to john he would catch it throw it
back to me
and so there was a flow that happened
very quickly there were ad-libs that
happened
that are not on the page they were just
from our heart from our love and from
for our and our respect for each other
the other thing that happened that
no one ever talks about is um so we know
in the sitcom world you get an
a story and a b story there's often two
or sometimes three stories happening at
the same time
so there's always one person for whom
that was their episode the episode
centered on something about them
so what's interesting is that we as the
rest of our cast would do what we could
to support that person so
we didn't go you want to go to lunch i
know you're rehearsing your lines or you
want to
is there anything you need there was
like sort of a support that would happen
to let that person just really feel
you know supported and loved and it
wasn't talked about it just happened so
i'm gonna give you a scoop
give it to me come on so we had a lot of
guest stars that came
on our show we had joyce dewitt and
several football players and
you know robin from batman and robin
like the real robin
uh uh eartha kitt and every week when
when we had our guest star come on
someone from the cast
would take them on as their like you
know
their their hall monitor it was never
spoken it wasn't like okay you take
earthquake this week and i'll take dean
kane next week it just
happened so we make sure that they knew
where where we were going to go to have
lunch and
you know is your dressing room okay is
there something i can help you with like
we just sort of
attached ourselves to someone so they
could feel so comfortable and my
favorite thing
is joyce dewitt who you know sitcom
legend
said announce to the audience i haven't
been on tv in a really long time and i
am having such a good time
this is the most fun i have ever had
shooting a show
that's because john was telling her how
pretty she was and we were like hey girl
how are you
and we just take them in and it was
really sort of a
family experience that you it's like my
job is to take care of so-and-so and we
didn't even talk about
how it was going to happen and so it was
really cool we had isabelle sanford who
came to the audience i'm having such a
wonderful time i'm like oh my god that's
wheezy she's a legend
and i kept kissing her feet i think my i
think that week she was my she was my
my ward anybody else that was a favorite
that came there
eartha kit or the kit because she didn't
really talk to the women that much she
talked mostly to the men hello darling
good morning good morning she said good
morning to us
but you tc darling how are you darling
john good morning
good morning everyone good morning hello
everyone she she came to work wearing
a turban a little warm-up suit and two
sets of lashes like bam bam
and some little wrist weights and ankle
weights so she could walk and exercise
the whole time
she was fabulous and we threw a party
for her and she was like darling done
she was
like pretending to smoke with the with
the like carrot sticks darling sometimes
you'll just have to smoke a cigarette
darling
like who is she she's fabulous it was
everything somebody made an interesting
comparison between um living single and
friends and they were saying what was
the difference between the shows
uh the difference was well the story
goes
that the president of nbc at the time
warren littlefield had said that
there's any show that you could have
bought this season what do you wish you
had bought and he said i wish i bought
living single and strangely a year later
friends came on or a season later
friends came on so the similarities are
that we were 20 somethings living in new
york
trying to make it the the big difference
is the melanin the other big difference
is the
the all the amenities and all the checks
um
and that was tough but we understood it
and to this day their people go
you know you guys came before friends
like yeah and and that's great and
uh yeah but the checks were very
different and even the treatment
it was a very different experience like
we had little um trailers in the middle
of the
parking lot like sort of it like sort of
shaped like an okay corral
like you know like all just protecting
each other do you all stay in touch
we do yeah and in fact we stay in touch
and there is an epic text thread
that is the cast and yvette
and we experience love and births and
deaths and marriages and
inside jokes and it's almost like when
something good is happening in our lives
we come there share it with each other
first before the rest of the world finds
out
so we're still friends the love is real
is living single gonna come back will
there be a reboot
you know what i always tell people i
always say that i've been neither
contacted nor contracted
so that means somebody needs to put it
together i would say yes
i think what it is is that you got to
get everybody on the same page about
what they want where they see the
what they see the vision for this show
to be um
i say we should do it while we all still
look relatively good i mean we all look
good yeah
let's get it done i don't know if there
will be one i would say yes if if
contacted or contracted the consensus is
yes if
if it's right yes if the script is right
yes if
if the script is right so i think maybe
behind the scenes there are some forces
happening to make that happen
i would absolutely say yes there's a
couple of holdouts that's all i'll say
after living single and which i think
could have gone on longer
it could have yeah why did it why did it
end you know what's interesting
they hired a new network president and
he decided that he wanted to
change the tone of the of the network
which is something fox did fox put on
black programming
and then it built up the network and
then they started to try to move away
from it
you had all these shows that helped
build that network and
was that frustrating you know what's
funny is i didn't think about it at that
time it was later on you go like wait a
minute
we built this this is uh
home and yet they kicked us out the
house and so
um you know kevin i'm not somebody to
dwell on that stuff i'm like okay what's
going on here
what's going on you don't want me here
anymore i'm gonna go someplace else i'll
be fine
it wasn't a tough it was tough at first
it was tough after after a living
it was tough and it was tough for me
because i
went through a depression because i
wasn't going to going to school every
day with my friends i wasn't going to
work every day
it was tough for me because i began
shopping i developed a
really intense shopping habit the screen
actors guild gave me 40 sessions of
therapy at a 20
copay i was like it almost pays to be a
little cuckoo for coco puffs
i got licks of some help and got really
understanding got really
present to i don't have to be on a tv
show to experience my gifts
or to share who i am or to be who i am
it's not about that
that's nice but i didn't do it to become
famous anyway i wanted to be carol
burnett and i have the chance to do that
listen people see you on a show they
think you're famous they think you're
happy forever they think that you're
rich for forever
so if i had been smart about my money i
could have and i did invest
at some point but it's still not going
to last for forever
one show is not going to keep you going
for forever forever it's what you do
with that money i chose to to shop
through mine and there came a point to
where
you need to work again it's not like you
that's it i'm done you want to work
again mm-hmm
okay here let me take you back i mean
i've always wanted to be
um carol burnett and lucille ball whose
voice is not so
young lily tomlin all rolled up into one
and that would be a very fat person i
know but
very that's where comedy is for me i
just want to work that's all i'm here
this is my dream this business working
in this business has been my
absolute dream to get that show was good
fortune
and and just an absolute dream and that
was part of
the building of my career and hopefully
i won't have to shine shoes on melrose
avenue
who said that okay can i tell you a
funny thing about those earrings
i did uh two episodes of star search so
when you do the star search they tell
you to come with six outfits be prepared
to do six bits
you know be prepared to to stay and so i
bought a bunch of different star
earrings and jewelry and i was gonna
wear them all on the show
well i won one episode and i lost the
very next episode
and then i had to start wearing all that
jewelry whether i won or not it was a
great experience so those are my
star search earrings i haven't seen that
in years oh my gosh
what would you say to her now oh wow
i would say continue to be
your perfectly imperfect kooky
self uh stay true to yourself
and let your yeses be yeses and your
nose be nosed
and know that it's all going to work out
the way you want it to
in the end i didn't have to shine shoes
on melrose
no no no and so that's a good thing uh
but to just
stay true to you and i and i have you
talk about the 90s and people from the
90s
and people especially were fans of the
show what do they say to you the most
when they see you besides they lose and
they start talking about sinclair
what do they say to you um
when is living single coming back are
you and overton really married
overton i have something to discuss out
in the hallway overton come along we'll
be right back
is that your hair
no i don't know and yes no no no no yes
i don't know yeah
um so they say a woo-woo-woo which was
my sitcom catchphrase
which people don't know is actually
something that my mother used to say to
me and my baby brother
like when words would fail her she would
go whoa whoa whoa sweetie
and so i ad-libbed that on the set of
living single one time and the producers
were like what was that
i'm like i don't know whoo khadijah it
ended up as part of the show so it means
i see you i love you i acknowledge you
so it's really mine and my mom's yeah if
you could do your own sitcom what would
the bucket list be
i would go back to that variety
show you know i i really did want to be
carol burnette and lily lily tomlin and
and all those things the show where i
get to play a bunch of characters and so
the other people so kind of like
a black lady sketch show would be
perfect and i got a chance to do an
episode of that too oh yeah yeah
awesome awesome so that would be a
bucket list it's something where people
could just come play create
and do good things a new and living
color new and living color
sure i'm just i'm living the good light
look what i love
listen would i love another sitcom yes i
would the sitcom
life is a good life there's family you
form family with your crew
right you um get a chance to put on a
play together
it's a good life to be on a set it's a
good life plus the
free hair and you get to have makeup
every all the time and free food come on
you